a main character and it's happened many
times on Game of Thrones
can be killed off and it's very
unexpected and shocking when it happens
and it's not the way TV used to work do
you get afraid every time you get a
script you flip through right away to
see do I live do I not live well we've
just finished
I've just finished shooting season 5
mm-hmm which we're around the area where
we're up to you with Marjorie in the
books so I'm entering into the
fraternity of what the gonna happen to
me now right that grand old fraternity
my grandfather was in that fraternity
yeah I've crossed a line and so who
knows I know as little as you know
that's not possible it's the nicest
thing anyone's ever said to me do you do
you have a wish if you decided you had
to go I mean there's some pretty
spectacular deaths on that show do you
have a wish how it would happen how I
would go yeah how would you how would
you go I've had it before right old
story
so poison that's how Jack went is
Joffrey that looks very painful even act
right I don't know maybe via dragon
would be good that's a fantastic one an
apt for the show yeah yeah white Walker
or dragon might be good a dragon
dropping you into a volcano you want
something that's got an extra bang you
know what I mean as you're falling a car
hits you extra bang for your buck
you